bonjour et bienvenue dans une émission
entre modernité et tradition
je suis à l'hôtel particulier de la
paille bas et nous allons vous raconter
l'histoire de ces faits tels particulier
celui historique qui porte le nom de
celle qui l'a fait construire au 19e
siècle
esther lachmann surnommé donc la bayard
mais avant je veux me rendre à la
fondation louis vuitton où j'ai rendez
vous avec daniel carriço neuf jeunes
pianistes virtuoses de 21 ans qui a
donné un concert en février
allez c'est parti de lisbonne à
vladivostok
[Musique]
c'est un petit prodige
un virtuose et daniel kharitonov
commence le piano à 5 ans
à 7 ans il joue déjà un concerto de
mozart accompagné d'un orchestre
en huit ans il remporte son premier
concours international
on
m
vraiment ce crêpage que ma mère est
violoniste alors que je n'étais pas
encore né
j'étais déjà dans la musique j'écoutais
de la musique et des mâts naissance j'ai
été entourée de musiciens mamère jouer
et donner des concerts constamment elle
jouait aussi dans un orchestre elle
m'emmenait souvent aux répétitions ou
jeunes immergé dans le métier de
logicien bien sûr quelques années plus
tard j'ai pris la décision de devenir
musicien d'avoir mon instrument voilà
comment je suis devenu pianiste
[Musique]
depuis sa vie est forcément rythmée par
sonar
c'est un passionné un travailleur
acharné consacrant la majeure partie de
son temps libre au piano
la musique ne lui offre aucun répit en
général les logiciens entente de la
musique dans leur tête 24 heures sur 24
7 jours sur 7
c'est très difficile d'autant plus qu'on
entend toujours de la musique est là où
d'autres peuvent ne pas l'entendre
supersport bastille c'est une sorte de
super capacités
c'est en quelque sorte la malédiction du
musicien revient le dimanche alors que
d'autres gens peuvent se reposer s'aérer
l'esprit en écoutant de la musique
moi personnellement je ne peux pas
lorsque je commence tout de suite à
analyser ce qui se passe dans cette
musique ce qui va suivre tout ce qui
concerne la forme la mélodie mais je
suis très heureux d'avoir cette
possibilité de comprendre cette langue
musicale à la fondation biton le concert
de daniel kharitonov remonte le temps et
brise les frontières
si la place et tchaikovsky au centre de
sa prestation
il retrace également une certaine
histoire du piano reprenant parmi les
plus grands classiques de beethoven à
chopin illustrant une fois encore les
liens culturels très présent entre
l'europe et la russie
m
nos stages stuff c'est le dff tous les
pays sont liés d'une manière ou d'une
autre nous nous ressemblons tous mais je
crois que la russie et la france ont
toujours eu des relations étroites
suffit de se rappeler le 18e et surtout
le 19e siècle quand presque toute la
noblesse russe parlait facilement
couramment français
c'était considéré comme quelque chose
qui allait de soi et nous avons beaucoup
en commun surtout sur le plan culturel
les français tout comme les russes ont
toujours été orientés vers la beauté
l'art dans tous ses aspects que ce soit
la peinture la littérature et bien sûr
la musique est fait les deux pays ont
beaucoup de musiciens et de compositeurs
qu'on entend qui évolue dans la musique
actuellement chercheur outre on inquiète
pas signé
j'ai beaucoup aimé sa façon du web et
hop tout en retenue l'adagio était
magnifique
beaucoup de sensibilité
quand même l'âme russe je trouve être un
des pianistes
c'est vrai ça se sent oui je trouve ça
dans la même façon de jouer les artistes
justement comme rachmaninoff chez comme
ce qu'ils trouvent que c'est c'est très
lié quand même à leur histoire
et alors
d'origine on est toujours très content
avec la qualité avec il faut imaginer il
a 21 ans impressionnant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais s'il est blessé on a bien fini tel
pays va t'elle pas il a été construit
par la marquise de pas eva et qui est
actuellement et le dernier hôtel
particulier sur les champs-elysées mais
là pour cela pour que vous nous accusez
nourrira contient tout petit peu ce lieu
magnifique n'est ce pas voilà je vous
propose de découvrir d'abord le grand
salon
il donne sur les champs elysées quelle
beauté alors c'était le qui était
destinée à la réception des invités de
la période exactement elle donnait des
dîners où elle était la seule femme
présente recevait une dizaine d'hommes
parmi des hommes politiques aussi est-ce
que vous avez bien de raconter à qui
était cette femme à la parade où elle
vient comment elle atterrit à paris
qu'est ce qu'elle faisait en france
c'était une russe alors c'est une russe
effectivement c'est une femme qui a une
vie qui sort du commun une vie pas
facile chaotique avant d'arriver au
sommet à paris de construire cet hôtel
elle est née d'abord en 1819 à moscou et
à l'âge de 17 ans donc très jeune elle a
épousé un dénommé ville loin
qui était d'origine française et elle
pensait à travers ce mariage que sa vie
allait changer
et finalement elle est arrivée à paris
et elle a commencé à paris dans une
maison close
jusqu'au jour où elle a rencontré un
dénommé r ce qui est un grand
compositeur de piano et elle elle a vécu
avec lui il
il est parti en aux états unis pour une
tournée de concerts et il envoyait
l'argent de ses cachets à la païva et
l'argent à peine arrivée des dépenses
est toujours en toilettes c'est avec et
jusqu'au jour où la famille d'hertz qui
était présente à paris voyez cet argent
fondent comme neige au soleil et donc la
mise à la porte et elle s'est retrouvée
à nouveau à la rue là elle est partie à
londres où elle a rencontré d'autres
l'ordre elle en a ruminé quelques-uns
mais elle est revenue en france après
fortune faite et c'est là où elle a pris
la décision de construire cet hôtel
qu'une maison qui serait le symbole de
sa réussite de sa réussite sociale et
elle voulait que ce soit la plus belle
maison de paris
[Musique]
ce qui est super beau si dans cette
pièce c'est les décors le plafond le
plafond qui est de baudry 1 qui
représente le jour pourchassant la nuit
alors le jour est incarnée par cet homme
qui représente apollon avec le soleil en
en auréole et cette femme avec le
manteau étoilé qui représente donc la
nuit et c'est la païva servi de modèle
exactement pour représenter la nuit il
paraît que dans cet hôtel particulier et
pratiquement tous les images de femmes
sont prêts sur l'image de la païva elle
a servi de modèle à pratiquement tous
les quais médaillon les tableaux ça
c'est exact c'est exact donc on a le
plafond de boudry mais également cette
cheminée monumentale de la planche qui
représente la musique et l'harmonie et
la statue de droite de la païva aurait
servi de modèle pour représenter donc
l'harmonie
on continue la visite ou continuer la
visite maintenant on va découvrir leur
jardin d'hiver qui est notre dernière
restauration qui a demandé plus d'un an
de travaux avec l'aide des monuments
historiques et donc la privation vous
voulez dans ces pièces étaient jardin
d'hiver entreposés cette lente l'hiver
aura quel jeune donc ça fait vraiment
une fonction aussi utilitaires et devait
avoir aussi du mobilier
pour profiter l'hiver des rayons du
soleil
[Musique]
l'hôtel paiva et surtout connu pour cet
escalier qui est paraît-il le plus bel
escalier second empire dans une demeure
privée en france bibeau tout court après
celui de l'opéra il a la particularité
d'être tout en onyx l'onyx et plus riche
et plus rare bien sûr que le marbre cet
hôtel a été construit si vous voulez
dans le style renaissance italienne dans
la suite des appartements privés de la
paille va maintenant on va voir la
chambre de la païva donc cette grande
pièce et vous avez en face de nous cette
très belle cheminée qui est donc en fait
avec deux de la malachite dural ski la
plus belle qualité de malachite eva ne
lésinez pas que je vous disais il
fallait que ça sert à rien la perfection
est maintenant là vous avez au milieu de
scènes pièce à contre mur dans cette
alcôve il faut imaginer qu'il y avait le
lit de la païva celui qui était donc le
poser sur une estrade une certaine
hauteur et de chaque côté de ce dit il y
avait un meuble cabinet mais ces meubles
napoléon iii noir
hélas cette pièce était la salle de bain
cette fameuse salle de bain le quai un
décor oriental parce que c'était
vraiment à l'époque la mode de
l'orientalisme je vais vous faire
découvrir maintenant la fameuse
baignoire s'il vous plaît voilà je sais
qu'il est maire voilà donc la fameuse
baignoire
c'est ainsi à la van loock d'onyx qui
est était donc évident et comme les
mêmes principes que les baignoires
romaine et à l'intérieur vous avez un
bassin en bronze argenté et qui est très
est assez profonde est assez grande et
donc c'est là que la païva prenez ces
bas alors il ya des looks n'y a plus
d'eau dia plus loin il n'y a plus d'eau
il ya plus de rien que ça y a pas de
tentation mais c'est super c'est merci
beaucoup pour que son nom mais merci
aussi magnifique on a eu énormément de
plaisir
c'était une très belle découverte merci
aussi au tour après bienvenue en revient
au noir merci d'avoir suivi cet épisode
avec nous on se retrouve très vite pour
de nouvelles aventures valmont de la
culture de lisbonne à vladivostok
[Musique]